[Music]
we talk a lot on the show about feeling
older about i mean the name of the show
is life is short about time moving on
and it's something that i've
grappled with since i was little but i
am
always surprising myself with certain
things i say that sound like an older
person
would say them like um what a nice young
man i've started saying things like that
but occasionally very rarely now i feel
like the young one and that is when i go
to florida christian and i were recently
there in um beautiful naples our friends
from massachusetts uh shout out to mick
and linda
mick and linda i hope they're listening
they were down there and kindly invited
us out on their boat we did some fishing
some uh
there's some drinking they're snow birds
yes they certainly are and they're
friends with a lot of snowbirds and
their snowbird friend speaking of birds
i don't want to reduce them to that no
no that's one but they they identify as
snowbirds yes they are can you identify
as a snowbird if you don't in fact spend
the winter in florida why not
yeah it's it's twenty-two
too but they have thick rust especially
it's thick they've stick massachusetts
accidents which is funny to hear down
there when you're so far removed from
massachusetts how are you oh yeah what
do you catch over there they've really
figured something out and i feel like if
i end up being something like them
socially in my later years i feel like
i'll be happy i would too you know both
of them feel happy if you figured out
that going to florida gives you peace of
mind and comfort um
anyway thank you for that bow and thank
you to our snowbird friends for uh such
a good time great time
life could be a dream
life could
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i am
your host uh you're not yet snowbird
host justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
and with me as always is my snowbird
loving
co-host and brother i aspire to be a
snowbird yeah i thought you wanted to
end up in japan
oh end up i'm but that's dying in japan
no you want to go there i would like to
live many more years before i die okay
so when you know that it's you're coming
to the end that's when you plan to go to
japan ideally
i have a lot of plans
but the florida one seems more uh
super doable i don't have to learn a new
language that's true you have to meet
new people you don't know anyone there
let's face it i do know some japanese
people oh you do and who live in japan
are we oh yeah owie cindy shout out to
owie and um yuki we made some friends we
did we sure did down there over there
yeah uh yes over there is it no oh i
should know this anyway who cares it's
over yonder
in that neck of the woods um but our
friends down in florida were uh we had a
great time with them and um what was i
gonna say about florida uh how well it's
it's still strange to me because we grew
up in connecticut and there's something
still so exotic about the the pun just
the palm trees alone i mean the foliage
palm palm
um
palm trees how do you say it pom pom pom
p-o-n that's p-o-m that's like prominent
palm clementine you just hit the l too
much palm palm
well because i want a diff because now i
know a palm
are you feeling calm
calm you're right calm
well i i think that's the proper way is
probably calm so why are we talking
about our snowbird friends well i'll
tell you why because our guest today has
the name snow
in her name has the name snow that's
right that was redundant she has the
name snow she does um and she's not yet
a snowbird she although she's from south
florida yes she is tampa bay shout out a
lot of friends there with too many shout
outs a lot of recent tampa guests
patrick wilson and um maybe that's it
two's a lot there's a lot yeah um funny
the movie i did with with brittany
recently uh what's her name oh did i not
say no oh boy i think i'm getting worse
at this you're getting older yeah maybe
it's time for you to become a snowbird
now yeah good nice
bow on a bow
um that that her name is what is her
name britney snow kyle britney so
brittany i'm sorry if you're listening
to this that i butchered your name on
the i didn't butcher it i didn't say it
yeah it's worse than butchering it
just you only eliminate it
but i didn't do it consciously um you
know i think i know her so well now that
i i'm just so familiar with her that i
assume
everyone knows who i'm talking about
recently did a movie with her yes it was
a talkie it was a talkie it was a
picture a motion picture um directed by
our friend claire shout out and uh
written by the great vince vaughn uh
friend of the show shout out and uh
hopefully future
whatever um and it was we did future
what snowbird no future future um friend
of the show peter billingsley oh yes
yeah he didn't write it uh anyway um it
was such a fun experience we talked
about that in addition to the movie she
just did with you christmas with the
campbells coming out
very well known for
the um pitch perfect movies yeah the
franchise the trilogy i saw all three of
them yeah
at the same time no
why why no like that like i'm sure
people do that at the same time you mean
three different screens
no oh no no i know back to back oh oh oh
i'm sure they have those i'm sure no i
didn't i watched them when they came out
what did you say
of course because you love women this
this is nice i appreciate
a cappella music yes um and you
went because it was acapella themed
uh in part and also it looked good and
fun and
i like the cast
who
really i like adam shank oh no he didn't
do that no he did it
but i like hairspray too he has uh do
you mean the product or the movie both
yeah all right um
adam devine i think was in it right was
that the actor you're trying to think of
no it was anna kendrick and
um brittany our guest today and um
who else are all your favorites oh so
much mentioned we love the cast ben
platts in it is he in the first one
okay you want to care to revise that so
he made let's let's admit it you went
because it was a cappella thing okay
okay is that is that the point you're
trying that's what i'm trying to get yes
uh and you were not disappointed no and
nor were millions of other people who
have seen it why don't you frame it that
way i wasn't disappointed of course i i
more than i liked it it lived up to your
high expectations yes
that's a better way of saying okay
so it was in fact pitch perfect to you
and she's now in
a really cool looking movie um looking
looking and i took a gander that trailer
and i hitched my eyes up to that trailer
and
i was not disappointed what's it called
it's called x simply x which was a
letter that always kind of excited me as
a kid just x not simply x right no no no
i'm saying it's simply called x okay the
letter x the trailer looks really cool
so cool there's um
it it takes place in the 70s i think
which is a time period i always love i
love watching movies from the 70s and or
or about the 70s and um it's about a
group of uh
adult film actors who go to shoot a
movie
um and in a in a creepy old house and
hilarity ensues
guessing and it said no it looks like a
very dark fun looks very scary scary
movie and um britney shot in new zealand
she was telling me about that experience
during the pandemic which was
interesting and so we get into that we
get into another
my appreciation of another star of the
movie kid cudi
um and a lot of other things she's just
such a sweet uh talented person and is
very open in this episode about some of
the things she struggled with and
some of her hopes and dreams and it's
fun so i'm excited for you guys to hear
it i'm excited
to stop talking i'm excited for you
christian to hear me no longer talk i'm
excited about that too um
here we go my friend the delightful
talented
britney snow
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
here we are here we are by the way this
is exciting only for us we're in a room
together i know it'd be funny if we got
not funny if we got coveted after this
but it would be
we would cut it we
would cut that part out we're in a room
together oh great a small enclosed space
with no ventilation
can i say this you had omicron i think
everyone's had it yeah i mean yeah i had
had it and so when we started our moving
together they said you might you know
have some residual because you keep
testing positive like what 90 days
yeah supposedly by last count
um
yeah so i they tested us together for
some reason it was in like little pods
how funny would it be to be like the
part of jesse will now be played by
they just brought in somebody else in
the third act during certain scenes you
may see
they do that on soap opera they used to
do that on
all the time when i was on a soap opera
they were just there which is a new girl
playing that part well you're no
stranger to soap operas and
people who might take over because you
watch them soap operas yes no i'm
kidding you were on one sorry i didn't
even really watch it when i was on one
oh you didn't because i was a child and
so i wasn't really allowed weren't you
curious like i wonder what my stuff
looks like i was i was curious about
what i was doing but i do remember when
i was a kid learning about things that i
shouldn't have learned about
before i should have sexual names sexual
things because i had to go to work every
day and and these adults would just make
jokes as we would bake now but i was 12.
so i didn't know what they were talking
about and so my parents were like maybe
you shouldn't be watching the show
because they wouldn't censor themselves
around you no i think because they were
everybody it was a workplace in there
and every and there was a crew and it's
very insular there because everything is
really contained in this one stage and
so everyone's just kind of
having a workplace environment and
there's little kids running around but
it's not a kid environment right it's
not nickelodeon right it's
did you think
do you remember any of them did so you
would you would overhear some of these
things and then go home and say
it's funny i have like the opposite
experience with my mother because my
mother was a middle school teacher and
she started picking up on things that
she didn't get that the kids would talk
like make jokes about uh-huh and one i
may have told this on the show but i
remember her coming home one day and she
would ask us what the kids were saying
like a word today and one day she came
home and she goes they were saying a
word i knew it was a bad word because
they would snicker after it and and we
were like well what was it christian
made the mistake i think of
saying like well what was it and she
goes it um it was like it sounded like
quiche like quiche oh my god what do you
think no i know what it is i think and
unfortunately for me well unfortunately
for christian
he goes uh immediately because as you
had that react realization he had it but
he didn't censor himself and he goes oh
you mean queef
oh just like a matter of fact and she
goes yes yes
you do this yeah i don't know
she goes to what is that queef what is
queef
he was a teenager i may have been early
20 we were old enough we were
embarrassed it was embarrassing
obviously to hear your mother go yeah oh
yeah no it's embarrassing for me and i
don't know your mom yeah she's the
nicest she's
she's a sweet lady and um she just
didn't know and she's smart she just
didn't know
that i wonder when that word came about
came into the vernacular it seemed like
it was very uh
popular at that time of our lives
yeah it
was
i'm really glad to be here justin thank
you for bringing me on your awesome show
and this is all that i wanted to ever
talk well life is short so we have to
talk about these are important things
that's a human truth that queefs happen
you can say it i can't you i can't you
second no i i i can't you know my
neighbor
a fellow who is i don't want to say how
i know him but he's an older gentleman
in the lives in the boston area and uh
he told me one drunken afternoon that
his mother never
like he confided in him that his father
never went down
on her
and vice versa for their whole lives
they were married
60 something years
and and we were i was talking to this
he's in his 70s this guy his parents
passed away and i was talking with
another 70 year old who couldn't believe
we were having this conversation he said
well what business is it of yours that
they haven't they didn't do that and i
said i don't know i was just
so fascinated by what that means that
like you can spend
i think they were married 50 or 60 years
with somebody and never
do that maybe that wasn't their thing
maybe they had other things that's true
maybe
wilder things wilder things yeah maybe
that was just like
blase
i didn't even think about that that it
was too like run-of-the-mill for them
yeah like that wasn't that wasn't gonna
do it so who cares um okay so speaking
of
speaking up so you're on the soap opera
and you're around all these adults and
your parents realize
you're picking up on things
it wasn't necessarily that i was picking
up on things just that i was i was put
into a really adult situation because i
was i was so young and i was basically
working every day and then going to
school in florida at the same time so in
tampa in tampa so i was like learning
all these things on the soap opera but
then i was also having to go back to
school and
and seemingly
doing that because i was supposed to be
normal right and have a normal childhood
but i it was like i was in two different
worlds
so they like they did that that was um
deliberate so that they could keep you
in a school system that was like you're
familiar with that makes sense but then
yeah that must have been weird to go
because you had told me this that you
were flying
you would fly to new york to do the show
get on a plane and come straight back
how often would you do that during a
week yeah it was back and forth three
times
[Music]
so i mean and i was i was 12 to 15. so
it was for a long it was three years
that i was kind of going back and forth
every week
and
yeah it was but it it was
sort of normal in a in a way because i
i just always knew that that was what i
was supposed to be doing as cheesy as
that sounds so it didn't seem odd
although that you know at school i felt
more out of place at school than i did
on the soba yeah i've heard this from
other people who did that at that age
and and i'm
recalling being that age and like if
there was somebody
god i remember when like uh soleil
moonfry had
she didn't even come to the school my
school that year she had been there like
a year earlier two years earlier and
kids were still talking about it it was
like
she was like an alien that that
everybody had a version of
oh i passed by her and i said something
to her so i knew that it had like a lot
of um
it was important to kids that age um but
kids also don't know how to deal with
like the unknown and
there must have been they must have
teased you i mean was did that come out
in that form or were they like impressed
by what you were doing
no i was definitely i was definitely
teased but i but i don't want to like
view it or or
shape it in this way
that it was because i think i was on the
show i think i would have been teased
anyway
there was this one
girl in particular and then there was a
bunch of other girls that kind of
followed suit and and i think regardless
of what i was gonna do i was gonna be
ostracized in that way and um what did
they single out like what what did they
attack you for
i was going through a really hard time
in middle school and high school and
i've been pretty open about this in
terms of like my
mental health journey but like that was
really the beginning of my sort of
understanding of like
what mental health was and i was just
like a weird kid i was going through
what i now know is depression and
anxiety and i had an anxiety disorder
but like i didn't know that as a as a
kid and so i got made fun of a lot
because i was really socially not able
to speak in front of people and i did
weird things with like my diet and
things like that and so
i think girls were just like really
super aware of of trying to make me feel
different because they didn't understand
it nor would they i mean no one knew
what and i didn't even know what was
going on well yeah kids that age also
attack um things they don't understand
and i don't fault them for that either
because i didn't even know what was
going on if you're not conforming i know
that's like um
i i remember that feeling of some of the
things i really regret in school um
were not speaking speaking up on behalf
of somebody who was getting
bullied and because i wanted so badly to
fit in you know i wanted to be i wanted
to
like recede into
the back the background um
i look back at some of those moments and
i think like god if i just if i had the
tools that i have now if i if i could
have talked to that kid and talk to all
of those kids like
you know you see clearly what it comes
from when you're older but um at that
time it's like them i just remember how
important it was to fit in and to oh
yeah i mean and i think that still kind
of
bleeds into today too right like we're
all just trying to be a part of
something and
and you know weirdly enough one of the
most like beautiful phone calls that
i've gotten
you know i think it was a few years ago
now but one of those girls actually
called me no kidding out of nowhere and
said this has been bugging me for years
and years and years and i'm so sorry we
were so mean to you no kidding that's
really cool yeah it was weird i was like
oh i totally forgot that you were oh my
god it's like that scene in billy
madison when
he calls up steve buscemi he's like yeah
yeah no no problem he's crossing off the
people to kill him exactly
i hope it didn't get that far but but
yeah well wow that's so nice that's so
nice
uh you seem to be to have known
that's exactly what you wanted to do
when you were at a pretty young age do
you remember
the spark do you remember the the first
time a feeling that you got from having
done it i was 12 and i was doing a scene
where i had to be
yelling at my mom character on the soap
opera and i was
already pretty sensitive of a child
um i had weird tendencies
that i that i now can look back on and
view as as pretty normal but but i mean
i couldn't even step outside of you know
into school with a wrinkle in my sock or
everything had to be perfect i was very
ocd and
i just was a really highly sensitive
kid and so i was really angry a lot
because things weren't in my control
yeah
and
so i had to do this scene where i was
yelling at my mom and
i just
yelled at my mom and it was the first
time that i actually like used that sort
of transfer yeah transference or
substitution i guess and
i
felt like oh this is
this is a way of doing this without ever
having to yell at my mom yes yes it's
safe it's safe yeah and i got to have
that cathartic
feeling and and then i thought to myself
wow this is what you know eating like an
ice cream cone feels like you get that
little rush yes i know totally yeah it
is i mean i've never done drugs or
anything like that at 12 years old so
i couldn't or drink or anything but that
was the closest thing that i could have
felt to
whatever that yeah i'm glad at 12 you
were wow that's like that's like doing a
line of cocaine
that would be a different
yeah yeah um well i i know that feeling
i i
did you ever express that to your mom or
was that something that uh
um i did and i think that you know our
relationship has grown
because of that because we both had to
realize that like that was you know and
i think every parent-child relationship
grows like that and i was in a very
weird specific circumstance so yeah
were you good at memorizing lines
because i know soap operas
i know so they they just throw all these
lines in so i was really really good at
it when i was a kid yeah and i
i unlearned
that skill because i don't know if
memorizing sometimes has anything to do
with
this is my own
this is my own description of this and
it's not factual at all or scientific
okay but i think that memorizing has so
much to do with your
level of confidence
and your
ease into which you're
memorizing something because when it's
almost like if you're holding something
really really tightly like nothing can
fit in yeah but when it's like loose it
kind of just like comes to you and
trusting your own brain that it's there
but the more that you're trying the
worse it gets and i think that over time
as i
became older
i would think about things more and as a
kid i just kind of like let it go yeah
that's true you're um naturally not in
your head about stuff like that right um
it's also
did
were you believing that you were in
these scenarios i mean when you were a
kid like was it easier for you to
accept that this person you're calling
mother is is your mother
no i never did anything like
that i i pretty much always used
i i don't no one ever taught me this i
was never even in acting classes or
anything like that but
i just always put
something that i knew
was real as the thing uh-huh yeah what
was it about acting in the beginning
that felt free that felt like you
gravitated toward
i think because i was an inherently
sensitive
kid and i could pick up on other
people's emotions
pretty well in terms of empathy like
you know some kid would be crying at the
grocery store and i'd be crying at the
grocery store all of a sudden i don't
know why i just kind of felt other
people's
stuff and i
i mean even
now if you tell me to think about
something i can think about something
and i can start crying
wow so i just kind of always wanted to
put that somewhere yeah and i think as a
kid you're like well what else is it
useful for
but sometimes this sounds like i was an
insane psycho kid and i don't even know
why i'm telling you this but
sometimes i would just like stare in the
mirror and make myself cry oh no um
no i i remember doing a strange thing
where if i was emotional about something
if i was crying something was depres
somebody something heavy happened in
life i remember this is we i mean i'm
now i'm telling you something that i
haven't done i remember looking in the
mirror
and thinking
try to remember this for if you ever
have to do that
you know this is what your face looks
like this is what you look like crying i
never thought it was a strange looking
face until i did an episode of new girl
where they
told me that i had i was a real ugly
crier what yeah and then they and then
they they said that to you
yeah oh yeah but i i i thought it was
funny and then they worked it and then
they wrote it into an episode and so it
was which was kind of fun because it it
i never thought of because you don't
think of
i guess i did think of my face when i
was crying but i don't remember thinking
well that's an ugly
i not that i was a cool crier but it's a
it's a thing that you do without really
thinking about what you look like i
think and um but then i got to think
about what would it like what would a
really ugly cry like i got to lean into
it because we had to do a montage where
i was just like
ugly crying was awful um
i think there are gifts of it somebody
sent me um oh my god what
what um
and then was american dreams a couple
years after that did you did you stop
doing the show go back to school and
then american dreams became i went to my
freshman year of high school
that was the only year that i was there
full out i did a year of school
and then um
yeah my sophomore years when american
dreams got picked up and i moved out
here
what was that like coming out here at
such an early age coming out to la i
know
weather-wise it was probably similar to
tampa we this sh this movie we were
doing in the snow
we were talking about how you just
didn't have the experience of snow
which which really blew my mind so when
you're in snow now it's uh
it must be exciting it is exciting
because i remember being a kid and and i
mean having the last name of snow people
just assume that i've had experience
with snow that's that's a great irony
yeah that is the irony i i'm from
florida and moved to l.a so it is it is
pretty fun like a lot of snow birds do
yeah
um what um are you proud that i haven't
made a pun about your name yet
i did you not during the movie oh i
definitely did drive no okay oh you mean
like right now yes um so so you came out
to la with uh still no snow but you a
lot of acting work and and american
dreams was like a really that was a
popular
show at the time i didn't have that much
acting experience other than guiding
light but i did have this very strange
sort of confidence that that i find
really interesting because i always just
kind of
knew i was going to get a show and i
just got american dreams and you know
you're just like a kid so it's just
you're not trying very hard yeah
um it was and it was so much fun i mean
i look back now and i think wow i i
think i was a kid and i took that for
granted because i just showed up to work
every day and kind of
did my job and now i look back and i'm
like that show was freaking cool yes
yeah it was a popular show
how long did it last three years um and
is that how you know shankman i mean did
you meet shankman through that or was it
it was it on hairspray adam shankman put
me in my in the first movie i ever did
called the pacifier oh
right okay with vincent diesel yes yes
what do you call vin diesel just man
then
i mean i haven't talked to him in a
while but i i did see him a number of
years ago
and he's like he's the best yeah was he
was he he must have been fun
as a kid to like be around he was so
much fun because i think he knew
very much so that he was doing a kids
movie and that was going to be his
mentality the whole time yeah like he
wasn't trying to be serious ever yeah
yeah yeah and playful and shankman is
what was shankman shankman is by the way
for
those of you who don't know he's he was
a choreographer for a long time but he
started directing big movies like
romantic comedies and stuff and um
he then went on to do hairspray
which uh you were also in was that um
and shankman's very
well imagine uh what you think of as a
choreographer
you know if you have an idea of a
choreographer okay you're going over
here
and you know and this is how it's going
to go and knows what he likes knows who
he wants and is very i wonder if he's
going to be insulted by this no
i think he i he does know what he wants
and i may see him at the gym in a little
bit oh really yeah you guys work out
together kind of that's we don't make a
plan to work out together but i see him
and we like socialize
um no i think that shankman i mean he's
just he's the best and he has like
the heart of gold
but he is really you know he's on it
he's on
he's on a [ __ ] and i think when i was in
uh pacifier i was i was only 17 at the
time so i was still a kid but we became
pretty good friends and i remember
you know i i grew up with
shankman i mean and then when i and when
the audition for hairspray came about
i auditioned for it and then i bombed
you right you said so shangman's
directing hairspray now it's this big
thing everybody wants this movie
um and it was that your first time
singing on at an audition i mean
american dreams obviously but no we i
didn't have to sing in america oh you
didn't
so yes it was the first time
that i ever had to sing and i'm
i mean i know you say this i suck i you
say this singing yeah and i suck at
singing in
it live
i mean i don't want to challenge you but
but you did i remember you singing a
little something
just kind of like to yourself when we
were on set and it was like beautiful it
was like you were like a little songbird
oh well
thanks but i mean i can sing
in like the shower by myself or even to
my dog i sing to my dog all the time um
like she'll be sleeping and i sing her
like a little lullaby oh that's really
sweet to imagine
do you
a specific song i sang her at last like
a couple days ago and pretend i'm your
dog no
i'll show you the video i recorded okay
yeah i'll play the video oh hey maybe
send it
uh you know maybe we can play it as our
um we do like a little voice memo at the
end of the episode oh okay okay that's
fine all right anyway when i'm live i'd
like to point out is the color of your
hair right now
yeah i for some reason i think singing
just gives me
you get anxiety i get anxiety and you
know it's funny because in x this movie
that i have coming out i have to
talk oh no we'll get there but
we just
people just assume that i sing and i
sing you know well and i think that i do
sing
well but for some reason it's a very
vulnerable
thing for me and i'm not sure
you don't know what to trace it back to
i think that hairspray was was hard for
me because i
didn't sing as well as i could have
right and so i have this sort of
memory of
not doing as well as i should have done
yeah yeah
uh and then but then i think people are
surprised myself included well i'm
surprised and i don't accept that you
don't you're not a good singer only
because i've heard you sing but on pitch
i mean pitch perfect became this huge
phenomenon and and so i'm sure
i'm sure a lot of the people who
know you as an actor like associate you
directly with a singing
role
was that but yeah and you sing in that i
mean you said that
like that wasn't smoke and mirrors no no
we all really sing yeah um i can sing
you know when i'm alone and i guess i
just like have a an aversion to my voice
i think it's very light it's very floaty
people have kept telling me to like i
remember
a long time ago people were like you
should start like smoking or you should
like be told
i mean i really like people would always
tell me an acting coach that i went to
back when i was like 24 25 she said that
my voice was too high and then i knew
penny marshall no i wish
[Music]
who doesn't like a good snooze if you'd
like to snooze more you might want to
check out caliper it's a dissolvable cbd
powder that has absolutely no flavor and
it's more effective than cbd oils
because it's clinically proven to
deliver 30 times more cbd in the first
30 minutes than cbd oil comes in little
packets you unwrap the packet you drop
it in the water and it it's fun to watch
it dissolve too if you're into things
like that
and again it's flavorless and but i love
flavors i often love flavors i love who
doesn't love a good flavor i apologize
to anybody who can't taste things god
when i was a kid i love root beer
i love citrus a nice refreshing crisp
citrus flavor a little little fennel and
you're good to go but um sometimes you
don't want flavors i like i don't
necessarily want a flavor right before i
snooze
that's why i love caliper
when the alternative feels like you're
eating a handful of grass flavorless is
actually much better there are these
little packets powder packets they're
carefully measured to contain exactly 20
milligrams so you can put zero effort
into figuring out your dosage and i
love not making an effort and it works
that's the most important thing it helps
with
stress as i said it helps me snooze
and um it you wake up feeling refreshed
you don't wake up with some kind of like
heavy
medicated feeling i can't recommend it
enough get flavorless with caliber cbd
get 20 off your first order with promo
code long at try caliber dot com slash
long you can try risk free for 30 days
if you don't love it they'll give you a
full refund try it risk free for thirty
days that's
tricaliper.com long don't forget promo
code long for 20 off your first order
hello hello
[Music]
do you sing in x you mention x i do i do
and is that was that something that
like triggered that anxiety or were you
more comfortable
it was a little bit of anxiety because i
had to sing
live and then i also had to sing in a
studio and i didn't know which one they
were going to choose
i don't i think it's kind of a
culmination of the both of them actually
but um
i'm much better singing live than i am
in a studio i just was never supposed to
be a pop star
like um
like when you think karaoke
i don't like karaoke you don't no unless
everybody's drunk and i like i like to
rap uh oh okay what's your do you have a
go-to we used to ask this question do
you have a go-to song
um it used to be gangster's paradise oh
yes but i can't do that anymore but
they're singing in that a little bit
the cool the i don't think i i yeah i
don't go there i just just talked
straight for the verse been spending all
our lives most of our lives
living in this gangster's parents yeah i
try to be really philosophical yeah
i pose the big questions
minute after minute hour after hour
everybody's running
what's going on in the kitchen i don't
know it's cooking oh yeah what's going
on in the kitchen yeah what does that
refer to
um boy are we white we are just so white
right now what's up uh
coolio um
have you ever met cooley i have not
but i do have to say like probably my
most embarrassing moment and i hate to
even bring this up because i don't want
anybody to watch it great but now
everybody's going to watch it i can't
wait is
i went on ellen and i and
the producer of ellen told me that i was
going to be rapping coolio for 10
seconds
and that it was going to be and it was
going to be an outro and that the lyrics
were going to be on all of the screens
and that ellen was going to do it with
me and it was going to be like 10
seconds and it was just kind of like a
funny little like thing that we're going
to do as we segmented out of
no our thing and in the middle of the
interview ellen just decided to cut my
interview short and say like i think
you're going to wrap something for us
and i said
and this is all on air i said well
aren't you going to do it with me and
she goes i don't know the words
they're on all the teleprompters by the
way
and i had to proceed to do the entire
thing by myself and i thought to myself
i'm going to go
down in flames if i do this because i'm
very white and i am very not cool and i
never thought i was going to definitely
not coolio
definitely not coolio
so i don't i didn't want to do it i
really didn't want to do it so you can
see my face and i'm freaking out and so
it's now
i'm surprised because ellen is known for
her
you know care and the empathy that she
expresses no
um sorry
well what um so you have to do the whole
thing then yeah oh [ __ ] that sucks it's
really bad do you mess do do you
remember all the words i do remember all
the words in it because hey they're on
the teleprompters but b
i also decided like i'm just going to do
this like as a school teacher like i'm
going to make it really really difficult
because you also don't want to sound you
don't want to affect any sort of i don't
i just didn't want to think that i was
trying to be a rapper you know like i'm
just like
right that's not it's one of those
things though if you don't commit to it
um if you're kind of like showing any
signs of embarrassment it is oh no i did
because i wasn't supposed to do it and
so it is
probably the most embarrassing thing
that's ever happened to me in my life
and so i brought it up just now and now
even more people are getting well i
remember going on trl once and they
to promote uh alvin and the chipmunks
and they had made up like a velvet red
cloak with that with a yellow letter j
which is supposed to look like alvin and
they they were like um oh we really want
you to wear this and i i so rarely do
this and i i def very rarely back then
but i was like
um you know i think that might be
embarrassing for me i'm gonna politely
decline if that's okay and they were
like
oh are you sure and they pushed it a few
more times and i
i said yeah i i am a people pleaser so i
really like it it took a lot for me to
say no
and um after the first commercial break
they said
somebody came over and they said
oh well you should i just want to see
if it fits like i want to take a picture
of something and
and i made it and i felt bad that they
had made it and so i was like oh yeah
here's to take a picture so i put this
thing on and it zipped up in the back so
someone had to zip me up this big alvin
cloak with a j on it and um
and then they were like i had it on and
they i said okay did you take the
picture
and they were like okay well we're back
in three
two and i said wait wait can someone
help me with and i'm fidgeting with the
zipper and nobody came it was clearly a
ploy to get me in the thing and so now
i'm st and they're like and we're back
trl live with like you know little like
kid like teen sitting around and like
and i'm wearing this thing and
again it's that thing where like if
you're not commit if i just been like up
here i am i'm bell but if i just leaned
into it it would have been fine it was
just like but i got so uncomfortable i
was like beat red and i was trying to
carry on like i wasn't wearing this
thing this ridiculous big j anyway i
feel you i feel like anyway and i will
have to also point out that our
embarrassing moments are probably
nothing to what other people are no
no it's not real no i know it's so funny
it's funny isn't it but but they live
they live on i know don't remind me
sorry
but it's good to like it's also younger
i got if i look back at some of those
some of the interviews i did when i was
younger trying to this is the worst
combination when you're trying to sound
casual and cool
and you're nervous yeah and you're not
addressing it i was just um
god i was just talking about how
how it changes everything oh we were
watching love on the spectrum and it's
so um there's something so refreshing
when the characters
uh the dates that don't go well are the
ones where they're trying
to pretend like this is normal and and
and they're not neither of them are
nervous and and there was one
where they both acknowledged their
nerves and they were like this is weird
for me
and they said oh it's weird for me too
and they were so much more comfortable
right they're talking about it but god
to
play off like you're relaxed and i know
it's crazy
i just feel like it's always better to
just
be real and call it out it is and
because people want to feel the same way
that you do your energy matches somebody
else's totally just like trying to we're
just all trying to get by we're trying
to fight i know
i know um
i know
i know those early interviews were
oh no one should have ever put a
microphone in front of me
from like before 25. yeah i was
yeah me too yeah i remember i remember
my first time on my only time on
letterman uh he was helping me out so
much he helped me out so much because he
could see how nervous i was but i kept
because i kept forgetting the story i
was supposed to tell he would redirect
me so anyway the car that you were
talking about oh that's nice yeah it was
nice um
but but you know like that and then you
sometimes you see it played back and
it's it's not as bad but in your head
the story that you tell yourself about
like you said crashing and burning like
i'm sure that cool that
no it's pretty bad
it's really bad
um
pitch perfect came around were you
anxious then to sing again was that part
of your reticence to to do those movies
no i it was part of my resistance
actually because hairspray was such a
um like a thing for me where i felt like
i didn't do a good enough job and so i
was really nervous to audition for pitch
perfect and i actually took two years
off of acting
i i was 23
when i was 24 i took like a total year
off that was deliberate like i'm going
to take this time off
i took a complete year off and so pitch
perfect was kind of one of the biggest
auditions that i had back and so i was
really nervous because i forgot
how to audition again
um
and uh
yeah it was really it was weird i think
i got it because they saw something in
me that i didn't see in myself because i
don't know how i got that well what did
these i mean
was it maybe a
maybe your nerves helped i mean was it
was it i think i was just inherently
that character and i think i brought
like a quirkiness to chloe that maybe
wasn't written i wanted her to be
uh it was jason moore the director and i
my idea to make her a close talker and
have no boundaries and all those like
little things i kind of think really
added to her just not being one of the
you know just a friend i think she had
her own sort of
weirdness she had an openness like there
was an innocent kind of to her yeah she
was just like slightly a little weird
and i think that i wanted to play her
like that and so i think that was
something different did you have any
idea that movie would be
what it would be absolutely not really
really i mean i knew it was going to be
special because i got the script for it
and i remember laughing out loud and i
remember calling my agents managers and
being
like coming out of retirement i have to
do this movie i basically was like i
will do anything i will play any
character i remember texting them that
and saying i will play any character
yeah um
as long as i don't have to sing
no that was that was a prerequisite but
uh yeah i just i just knew it was going
to be really great i had no idea it was
going to be that big but i knew it was
going to be something special had you
sung a cappella before
no never
was that ever something because
my brother's curious because he was in
an acapella
band
yes that's cool he was in a band um
shout out to the colgate 13. um so so
when when
kid younger people do come up to you
um and mention that movie what what form
does that usually take i mean what what
kinds of things because val and she had
a very specific connection to it which
was it actually
well this person who came up to you
when that we worked with had a very
specific connection to it which was it
inspired her to
come out i think and to know that she
was queer
um had you heard that before was that i
have heard that before and i think that
it's so incredible i mean yeah really
incredible because i can remember the
movies that i watched when i was a kid
that inspired me to realize things about
myself that i hadn't put a name to that
i just had like a feeling yeah um
or that i was like searching for
something when i was watching movies and
i think that's what movies are all about
is like recognizing yourself yeah um in
these characters and realizing that
you're not alone obviously someone had
made that film and so they had you know
they thought of that thing so i remember
those movies for me and so to be a part
of a movie that could be that for
someone was
is always really important
yeah what do you i know and to hear that
yeah what do you say i mean what do you
say to somebody who who
i mean i just gave her a hug and i just
said thank you because
it really does mean the most to me
i think we all are just trying to like
do something that
feels like we're making
something make sense for people
even if it is so
frivolous
i know i know well that's why em you
said it better earlier when when you're
doing these things that are that are fun
i mean really like they're just the fun
and you're con concerned with your own
job and and your role in the thing so i
know you don't really think that god
this might this might really touch
somebody this might affect somebody and
um i'm sure a movie like that was was no
different
x might also have that effect
i don't think x is going to inspire
anyone too
i don't know if i think it'll inspire
something but i'm not sure if it's uh
maybe we shouldn't dig too deep on what
it might inspire because it's the
trailer is
wild
wild yeah it's an 824 movie and
i got to know you doing this christmas
movie and so to see you then
in that role like just a few glimpses
was like a complete you had mentioned
that to me
but man is it a totally different thing
for you it's horror genre but you're
doing a lot of like adult film stuff in
it too was that right
how do you get comfortable doing
something like that do you mean
specifically like the porn stuff yeah
yeah like the the adult stuff the
naughty stuff yeah yeah
i think for me
i am 35 and i spent a lot of my years
and a lot of my time not that i'm that
old but you know sounded like 100 years
old just then but a lot of time
in my 20s and my teenage years hating
myself
in terms of like my body or what i
looked like or my femininity or
sexuality and i think that
this was something for me as a challenge
to
have autonomy over
myself and my body and and not to do it
in a gratuitous way where it was
shock value or showcasing something for
no reason
she had motivations for
everything that's in there is because of
her own agency yeah of her own
you know confidence in her
character and so i think that
you know maybe some people will disagree
with it but i don't really care yeah
well good yeah no i i i just i think i
meant more in terms of so of um
you're kissing you're touching
somebody's lips which is like that's
what that's reserved for right yeah
i mean i'm not gonna make it seem like i
don't
have that weight to it you know i think
it's even kissing scenes or or anything
like that but luckily
scott
yeah kid cudi and i are really close in
terms of friends and
um
we kind of just made it funny yeah i
mean you gotta make it funny and it's so
not that i mean i look at something like
boogie nights or something like that and
i think to myself wow you know how did
they do that this is more
in a campy sort of
way of of
we're almost making fun of it as we're
doing it as these characters right so
there is that sort of like
meta yeah aspect to it that makes sense
and and if you know the person i like
that you
by the way i'm gonna hit you up for kid
cudi you have to
text him for me okay
because apparently he likes me who does
he tweeted something that's not about me
which i'm talking about all the time
uh it makes me really uncool oh my god
but he tweeted his appreciation or
something
no he's the best he's he's the best and
scott
scott yeah yeah i
i don't think i should no i can't come
connie either i'm not that cool oh yeah
cuddy
he is very cool uh and and you're right
you kind of have to laugh at that stuff
especially when it's like
sort of making fun of the genre anyway
and we are we we are performers in the
movie making a porn so
we are making fun of so yeah something
in the 70s yeah it's already sort of
over the top yeah that's true um
well i can't wait to people must oh you
must be sick of answering this when
people people are like uh oh did was did
anything really scary happen while you
were making it was it scary to make it
it was a little scary because the house
that we filmed in i i think was haunted
oh no [ __ ] i i mean nothing really
happened to me but i
i might sound like a crazy person but i
really believe in that sort of yeah no i
love that stuff i love that stuff wait
wait what makes you say that about this
house um first i was in new zealand
right new zealand and we were kind of in
the middle of nowhere and the house was
very old um
and uh
i think that some of the crew you know
there was doors that slammed and things
that fell off the walls and and things
like that no kidding it was cuddy at all
the rest of this interview is it's just
about me like asking
questions through you uh
so what do you think cuddy's favorite
role uh what that's i also um
i was really amazed by how your the
quarantine process that you had to go
through yes you so we tell people what
happened you get to new zealand which is
obviously an island and they were very
good about
uh they were good they were
good at about covid they were i mean
there was i think
one case yeah when when we showed up
there there was one isolated case in the
entire country so crazy it was pretty
amazing because people were out
going to concerts you said and living
life and it's like this is like the
height of the pandemic too it was last
year
oh my god and so you go there and they
make you so you have to stay everyone
has to stay in the same hotel right for
two weeks
i'm sorry not 2020 2021. um we had to
stay in a government mandated
hotel yeah and you stay there for two
weeks in one room
and um wow you just
sit there oh man do you have what do you
have in the room yeah is there oh you
said there wasn't a bike
no martin actually martin henderson um
he he brought a bike a spin bike but i
did tybo oh yeah you did typo oh yeah
uh a bit like billy blanc yeah billy
blanks um i don't know why billy is my
trusted
person in that sort of i mean yeah but i
think you know high school i did billy
blank so i just wanted to represent i
guess yeah billy blanks
it had the stuff
that's what i and i watched a lot of
movies oh yeah what were you watching
were you watching like stuff that from
childhood like older no i was watching
movies that i knew that no one else
wanted to watch with me
like eight and a half or like you know
like fellini and um like
i don't know paris texas oh you know
like classic movies that you kind of
just
feel like oh i can't believe
yeah that i mean i have to watch this
movie you know that's right we have a
question coming up on our lightning
round that um
that that is in a movie like an
acclaimed movie that you're embarrassed
to admit you haven't seen but that would
be a good occasion to
catch up on all the all of those like
and i and i even watched like not even i
mean they're critically acclaimed but
ones that like terms of endearment
yeah and it was one of those movies
where
um and shirley maclaine like yeah
i'm yeah and um
i mean there's a scene in that that
everyone cites and always quotes and i
always i'm like haha like i know what
you're talking about no i remember once
oh my god i remember shooting with a
bunch of actors my age and
and we were talking about doing the
scene
and they said we should and i was like
uh-huh uh-huh and i was stoned i
remember so i was a little like aha but
i was like agreeing with we should shoot
it like this like
whatever
handheld on a br and they said like like
uh my valent a blue valentine oh yeah
and i go i go aha and i just started
saying uh-huh and then
the conversation turned into how great
blue valentine was and i couldn't say
and they i had already said uh-huh i had
already said positive so a couple days
later
i was um with some of the same actors
and uh
and and blue valentine came up again and
i go
oh my god i can't i got to see that i
can't wait to see that and you know ari
green her ari was like oh yeah not
personally
she busted me she goes what are you
talking about i thought you saw it
and i had a sheet a couple days earlier
she had been in that group um
and i still have never seen
what i know okay
oh my it's one of my favorites if i said
that two seconds earlier
i mean it's a hard you know that's the
thing with movies that are
you know that you're going in and it's
going to be sad yes i mean well that's
why like 12 years a slave right still
still have not seen it i've not seen it
either
and you know that i know what happens i
so do i but i'm gonna tell you mine and
it's it's very much in the same
genre and vain i've never seen saving
private ryan yeah every time i go to
watch it i know that i'm gonna cry and i
know i'm gonna be sad and everyone's
gonna die and there's so many people
great actors that i love i just i can't
do it it's hard i know are you planning
you do you think you might see it one
day
i'll watch it when you watch blue
valentine oh okay
she'll call each other and we'll say
okay we're about to cry and then we're
gonna get like cry together like on the
phone man saving brian that's a good one
for that's a really good one for being
and i get why you didn't see it i
totally get it
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
lightning round okay
what is your favorite emoji
britney snow what's the one i use the
most or what's my favorite oh you know
both i i we usually don't make a
distinction but no i'm not curious well
the one that i use the most is the guy
that's like this britney's giving a kind
of like
like a smile like it's the side half
smile that's like
yeah
yeah
kind of like a little core
toy
or this or the monkey that's like this
i'm covering britney's covering her eye
yeah it's just the eye covering one just
the eye covering because i'm like
embarrassed all the time like i say
something and i'm like oh sorry oh
that's why i use this one uh the one
where he's bearing his teeth sorry
um that's funny try the monkey next time
i will i love monkeys so people might
think i'm using it in a different
context
i really have you ever met a monkey have
you ever like touched a monkey i have i
have i mean we're not like friends still
oh yeah but but i've met thank you yeah
i don't know if he remembers me but i
remember him what was the occasion that
you had well i'm from tampa florida and
there's busch gardens and you know
there was like little tours that i went
on i met a sloth i met a monkey
you know
things like that nature and this slot
what was the sloth like you guys it was
a famous sloth i forget his name i'm so
sorry to the famous sloth um but i got
to take pictures with him mia sloth
that's a reference also to eggs mia goth
slop i got i got it thanks
thanks katie's katie's judging me harder
harder than she touches are you this
emoji with the
hands over the eyes after that one yeah
i will need that yeah uh that would be
the i might use the red cheek to like
smile like sorry with the hands up
yeah
uh yeah that's a tough one but mia goth
is in your movie mia goth isn't x which
is um out march 18th yes out maybe now
maybe it's out now
who was your first celebrity crush
leonardo dicaprio yes i had a huge leo
poster yep he looked over me uh when i
was sleeping yeah i and he was from
titanic from titanic and i had also a
binder it'd be funny if it was from
another movie well football straight
no um
no it was from romeo and juliet weirdly
enough him with like the hawaiian shirt
that was like flying open yeah
yeah
yeah yeah i had a binder that was just
devoted to him what was in it letters to
him oh that um that you had sent and he
sent back he said once back no just like
me talking to him and did you ever have
occasion to run into him i did run into
him a few years ago but he doesn't
remember this how do you know because
i think there's like no way i danced
near him oh okay all right
he
how close did you get
this sounds so a couple feet away
uh what must it be like to be him to
just brittany's fanning herself
i think both out of embarrassment but
also like no i'm embarrassed okay yeah
i'm i think because it just sounds so
lame that i remember this no
i i'd remember if i danced near leonardo
gabriel yes i remember dancing near
kirsten dunst when i was younger at a
place called don hills and um it was
this cool it was for like nyu students
and they played great
thursday was 80s night and
saturday was brit pop night so it
introduced me to all this like really
cool music and every once in a while
there was like a dj from um
what was his name alex
from the band phantom planet oh yeah you
remember them yeah
yeah and um they would play that song
cal phone yeah they would play the
california and uh all the like cool
people would come out and kirsten with
her friends would go every once in a
while and i would dance next to her near
her i that her friends always formed
like a barrier like a protective wall
around her i remember um and it's funny
is now i i
know her i know kirsten and and her
friends and and some of them are um is
there still a wall are they uh no i
broke i broke through the wall years
later um but they it's funny it's just
funny to be able to put a you know to
know the people that you were just faces
to you and were just kind of in the way
of something that you really wanted i
mean this
only pertains to you i i never really
wanted leonardo dicaprio yeah that's
true
but you were but but to dance it also
must be like to meet people like that
i've had that experience too where you
meet a childhood crush and
there's some like meg ryan i mean
there's something
when i remember working with her there
was still
a lingering
something leah thompson
on the show i i was kind of
tongue-tied around her you know i know
um she's the bad you know yeah yeah
what is your favorite ice cream flavor
uh cookies and cream
cookies and cream what is your favorite
holiday pretty looking off
patriots day patriots day because of
saving private rights yes because you
were so
influenced by that movie um like
memorial day or it would be
july
veterans day i guess you know actually
really enough i'm gonna say fourth of
july and that's not too weird to go back
to save a private ryan but i really
enjoy
barbecues i like being outside
an excuse to be like i don't know in red
white and blue and set off sparklers oh
it's the best yeah that is not
controversial at all um
well what is well here it is an
acclaimed movie you're embarrassed to
admit you haven't seen we we've covered
this
um
but
do you know so okay so if i see
a blue valentine
you will see that all right no and we'll
and i mean it's longer i i gotta say
your yours will be
more of a time commitment more more
crying well actually probably about the
same amount of crying i think more like
it's i will say it's such a visceral
experience like the sound of the bullet
i mean it's the whole first 20 minutes
the whole story of the beach i i do have
to admit i've seen the first couple
minutes oh oh that's the toughest stuff
well that's why i haven't watched the
rest oh yeah is because i couldn't get
through it
and and you'll probably be upset to
learn like if vin because i know you're
friends with van if he his character if
anything bad happens i will say
i'm pretty sure he makes it through
you're just saying that no no i'm pretty
sure he does i mean eventually his
character
probably passed away right you know um
but okay
what is a game show pastor president
you'd want to be a contestant on
wheel of fortune yes
i love wheel of fortune um
do you drink coffee or tea and if so how
do you take it i
i am shoot two sugars
two stevia two creams oh yeah stevia two
stevia two cream
tea are you into tea yeah i like tea um
but i also like it with two stevia
one cream okay huh um if you could learn
another language what would it be
french
french quickly said that yeah
oh hey can you talk about the movie
you're directing sure yeah it has any
movement on that any yes we're we
start in april great my first day
shooting days because i know you had a
moment of panic those i was telling
brittany like because chris and i we
listeners at the show are sick of
hearing us talk about lady the manner
but but um
before you shoot it's always it's it's
such a roller coaster i had a
breakdown with you on a mountain
basically because we almost lost
it all and you really talked me off of
that mountain ledge i just knew it's
like it it'll be okay those things and
when you told me the problem that's when
i was like uh no no no it's gonna be
fine it's and it ended up good i'm glad
it is good good
and it's um
and uh well we shouldn't talk about
unless cuddy's in the movie and you want
to kiss me
yeah that's so funny
so cuddy and weirdly enough he is in the
movie and daddy i don't know if i'm
allowed to officially maybe but actually
by this time it probably will be
announced but a bunch of my friends
um are doing me a great solid and being
in the movie and then we have some other
really great people in it that are not
my friends yet that are also in it and
i just feel really lucky that i'm
finally getting to do it's been four
years
and and and it has to do with what you
had touched on it briefly but um
something that you went through
when you were younger and it's uh i got
i i just love the idea that you were
turning
a personal pain something that you that
was a struggle into something that i
think will probably really positively
affect you yeah i hope so i mean really
the movie is about
codependency in all its different forms
and how that takes shape in terms of
people in terms of behaviors in terms of
you know food or alcohol or things that
you use to escape yourself yeah and how
we sometimes rely on those things to not
be present and to not feel what's
uncomfortable well i won't be able to
relate to that at all but i think most
people will um i'm kidding i can
definitely that's uh yeah that's great
i'm glad you're doing it yeah yeah what
is your favorite cereal britney snow um
honey nut cheerios oh yeah classic
classic mm-hmm just with the bee
i just like like he was so friendly i
know and i just really
it was one of the few that we could with
that like healthy
mother we could we could eat um that was
like a little
naughty a little sugar yeah it had a
little uh kick um
if you had to choose a different first
name brittany's a great name but if you
had to choose a different one what would
it be
i always like names that have also
initials that go like my jk like jk my
mom her name is cinda but her middle
name is joe and my dad always used to
call her cj and i just like i like cj
yeah i like
initial names uh cinder huh
from lucinda
weirdly enough no my my grandmother had
two sets of twins
cinda and linda and then kenny and karen
cyn and linda
adorable she couldn't find anything to
na to rhyme with linda so she just came
up with cinda yes she she wanted linda
that badly she did she loved linda wow
uh pinda
no i guess what yeah nothing rhymes with
linda
belinda galinda
glinda
no that's not a glenda that's yeah but
that's not really rhyme uh and then
karen of course is
karen that's kenny so is karen still
karen with us
yes oh dude i'm curious have you talked
to her about the the
karen yeah the change that her name has
gone through she i don't think so i mean
i'm sure she's thought about it but i i
have not brought that up at a family
reunion i know it's awkward you don't
want to do it yeah like so aunt carrick
sucks for you you know i know my
uh great grandfather's adolf and i i
felt the same way about him kidding i'm
kidding sorry that's not katie shaking
your head sorry
um it's ruined no it's ruined that name
i think that name was popular in austria
he ruined it
i mean that's one of the
least bad things he did obviously uh i
think one of the worst is also that he
ruined the charlie chaplin mustache he
we you've brought this up before have i
i think so i'm fascinated by it because
that mustache because giant well that
was a big that was really cool
it's a big deal no it was it was very
popular there's a huge star right it's
like it's like if some it's the world's
biggest [ __ ]
just adopted i'm trying to think of like
like tom hanks's look or like
he's probably the last person to say
because he doesn't have um
except it's tom hanks trying to think of
something like lovable yeah yeah that's
true uh if you had a sandwich named
after you what would be on it the
britney snow sandwich would be what
there's this this one sandwich that i
get and i only get it when i go home to
florida for christmas
and it's from this particular place and
it's
i'm just going to preface this with i
don't eat this all the time because it's
a very specific thing and i don't want
to sound gross here it goes okay okay
it's this is a once in a while yeah once
a year treats
it's like turkey
with like mayo
ranch mustard pickles lettuce onion
on
toasted white bread with the crust cut
off it's really good and they make the
sauce whatever the sauce is
it's the mustard of the mayo and the
ranch all in one so you can't really
tell it's gross
you could just kind of think it's sauce
so where's the sandwich from because
maybe if you shout them out anna's deli
it's on midnight pass road it's this
little sandwich shop deli in tampa and
it's called they have this signature
sandwich called the surfer i don't get
it with the ham but they have a like a
special sauce okay that
i'm pretty sure is just mayo mustard and
ranch and um it's disgusting but it's
also
fantastic yes yes i i well my goal now
is if nothing else comes of this make
you friends with cuddy and me having a
sandwich a couple maybe a couple people
see x yeah well okay maybe but but
mostly
friends with cuddy
and um watching the ellen gangster's
parents oh vindy's will be great to have
on the podcast too oh okay i'll call vin
okay
uh anna's deli so and and the britney
smith so hopefully they'll call the
britney snow
that would be that's the version without
ham right mr bernie snow do you want it
snow style snow style um
okay it's like a cartoon character but
it's no style
what is your favorite i hate to bring
this up again your favorite tom hanks
movie
oh
is that a real question yeah it's a real
question oh wow you love tom hanks
splash splash yeah
love it yes
i just
i think john candy john candy is so good
and so memorable that like i i know he
had a smaller part in that movie but
it's the first thing i think of
well because he has such a presence
obviously yes yeah and he's just the
racquetball scene i mean he is like the
philip seymour hoffman of like that
scene you know where you're like yeah
the racquetball scene kind of reminds me
of rain dance
in a long time polly yeah yes that
you're right i never thought i never
put that together would you rather take
a time machine to the past or the future
oh past past is there an era that you'd
particularly like to
look around the 70s yeah for sure was it
before you started doing the movie oh
yeah i mean because of american dreams
the 60s and the 70s were always kind of
i just became so obsessed with the 60s
oh man my was wonder years i bet a lot
of people have that from watching
american dreams but i do from watching
the wonder years
yeah that's funny and i think because we
had to do so much research for the show
i was always kind of fascinated that
there were so many similarities of what
people were going through we just had
different outfits it was very i know
it's very weird how similar a lot of
stuff just keeps replaying until we
learn our lessons i know are you more of
a talker a texter
oh you mean on the phone yeah i i'm more
of a texter um
i think because i'm pretty talkative and
i don't want like if i have a
conversation with my my parents or with
a friend it's either going to be an hour
long or two minutes like there's not
really like in between
um and i hate that for me and for other
people i wonder how this is going to end
now
uh we're almost over night or morning
person i'm a night person yeah you have
a ritual do you have a routine yeah i
mean i do a lot of reading at night um
and
i just stay i i come alive at night i'm
just a terrible morning person yeah
beecher mountains
oh for some reason i thought you were
calling it like beecher mountains like
it was like a like a club it's a weird
way to get into it
i was trying to like do a definitive
starting for sure beach yeah
toilet roll over or under
over
are you done with this oh yeah but i'm
okay
okay we're almost done oh i'm fine okay
uh over
yeah it was yeah i'm not a puller yeah
yeah i don't like pulling it yeah it
will i don't want to come like come up
it's harder to know too where the
perforation
um finish this sentence britney if you
will life is short so
um
[Music]
life is short
so
so
party
party
i don't know party
hard um
well it's fun it's funny when we were
walking in here we um
uh we were walking into wandery yeah uh
we went through uh another door
from the parking garage and it opened
into this like restaurant thing we were
both having this
feeling of deja vu and it looked
familiar and you were the one that said
oh [ __ ] this is bootsy bellows yeah
because when i was in my 20s
i
i went to bootsy balance yes that was
the place yeah it was the place i it's
so funny because now i don't even
remember the last time i think the last
time that i like partied was with you
the ending of the movie yeah i don't
even know hardly called party that was
like a dinner
yeah we partied i mean i never i didn't
have a drop of alcohol yeah but i i just
find it so fascinating that at that time
of my life at 22 yeah that was
completely acceptable to go to bootsy
bellows like every i was talking about
this recently like every night
especially when you're not working as
actors i mean two actors not working
every night it was good it was it was
definitely a distinct time where that
was
not only acceptable but it was almost
required
like you would like you would go out
well you told me about
what was the place where younger actors
because i wasn't an actor
at this age but you said there was a
place where
younger actors like before oh yeah they
were of legal drinking age what was that
called it's called club one seven club
one seven club one seven and who do you
see who would you see on a typical night
at club one seven i'm not gonna call
anyone out even though i don't know if
everybody would be mad about it but
pretty much if you were like on a show
and you were under the age of
19
you would get into this private
club or like but it was a normal club
but then there was a private room and
would they serve alcohol no just punch
punch no alcohol okay but you got to be
in this room and you got to go through
this velvet rope and you felt really
cool because you were like 15 16.
but everybody from seventh heaven
any nickelodeon show any disney show
dawson's creek is that two old two no we
were specifically under 17. okay you
know who would love this place is sarah
ramos did she ever go i i took her oh
you did so sarah i took her what's that
so sarah was on american dreams and she
and then was on parenthood really great
actress funny um but she now she does on
instagram she's very funny to follow
because she does like classic scenes
from movies that she loved growing up
right and we both did one and you did
who did you do again uh sweet home
alabama oh right you did uh with melanie
with melanie yes um this scene with mel
uh so funny but sarah
loves she has a book about called
autograph hound i think where it's like
she's meeting famous people and stuff so
she must have she must have been like a
pig and [ __ ] in this she
she went i think with with me but also
we would go to these
premieres and god
the outfits that we would wear and the
things that we would do i mean we were
early 2000s we were 16 and i would wear
dresses with jeans under them and ugg
boots at the same time and i brought
sarah and it was always so funny because
she's still sarah it's the same person
she just would be so
excited to meet
anybody and everybody and she had her
little autograph book and
um she's really made that something i
mean it's really cool it's very charming
that um she does but is it i i remember
going to premieres that i i wasn't i had
nothing to do with
remember that like oh it's a
it's like why was i
kangaroo jack
maybe you're a big jerry o'connell fan
um by the way it's jerry's birthday
today is it yes best friend of the show
well i was at kangaroo jack so yeah i'm
sure he knows me hi i'm sure he'd be
like oh yeah she's oh she's cute britney
snow
um
oh yeah anyway anywho uh well here we go
see i don't want it to end i know part
of it is so lovely yeah it's also just
so good to see you i know i mean it
hasn't been that long but now i feel
like this should be like a running a
thing let's do it i'll just like keep
keep you updated with saving private
ryan okay oh that's going all right and
i'll let you know god
the only thing that's gonna like put a
damper on our friendship is that we're
never gonna watch it well every time i
talk to you i'm gonna feel some slight
tinge of pressure to watch blue
valentine
um but this has been so fun it was so
fun working yeah it's so fun i'm glad
we're butts yeah me too
so that just happened so that just
happened just neutral keeping it neutral
just neutral huh well it's hard for me
to be insulted by that no no i don't
mean that i'm she's neutral i'm not yes
i'm not saying that okay i'm saying out
of respect to her i won't even attempt i
see to do how she sounds but you
wouldn't refer to her her voice as
neutral she has a nice voice she does
she really does
i stumbled over that because i was going
to say something else what were you
going to say i was going to say it's
hard for me in general to do female i
don't mean this
i don't want to be offensive it's hard
to do female voices because i have what
i have biologically male anatomy can i
say that
yeah and and it has
caused my voice
to be a little bit
deeper we have testosterone yes yes i
can't help that
it's just a fact i'm just stating a fact
that i hope to offend anyone so you're
so you're saying it's hard for you to do
female voices yes so when i do a higher
voice i mean if i were to do do somebody
it would sound like kind of caricaturey
i think yeah that's true um but brittany
does have a really lovely voice she's
got a lilting voice
yes there's there's an innocence to it
very down to earth totally and
for an actress i know i have bias when
it comes to actors and actresses except
for the cast of pitch perfect of course
uh so i'm always a little favorite i'm
always a little bit
surprised when an actress is so down to
earth well i feel intelligent i think
what you're alluding to is that you have
seen you've socialized with a lot of
actors and actresses and you have seen
at behind the curtains yeah and
obviously actors and actresses tend to
be you've seen them when they're not
performing they tend to be very charming
people and very fun to be around yeah
but they're not always the most
intelligent people
well or down to earth who are you
thinking i don't want to stop
but this show can often any podcast is
also a
it's a platform that can potentially be
of a performative nature of course but
she seems like someone that i could meet
in any walk of life yeah you know
you would you do like her life i do like
i mean i like what i've heard from her
she was being
her really very and very open
very um yeah honest and open and
intelligent it's interesting because she
does as she mentioned struggle with
insecurities and she um
she voiced some of those to me
afterwards you know did i say too much
was this the wrong thing oh really yeah
and i said um which i i stand by i i
thought what she said was is only going
to be useful to people and i thought it
was really valuable for especially
younger
women younger people to hear um
so that somebody like that can have
those struggles
very surprising that she's insecure
about singing and no i'm such a
beautiful voice well i think you know
there was somebody on
pitch perfect who who made her feel bad
about it it was not an actor it was it
was somebody behind are you sure was
pitch perfect or was it oh i'm sorry on
on hairspray yeah and um then she didn't
want to die fold she didn't want to call
anyone out but but um i think that had a
lot to do with somebody in a position of
power made her feel bad it's also crazy
what ellen did oh man i watched that
after i see it's pretty shitty it is it
is um for some allen's a performer ellen
knows what that's like that how
er you know how um vulnerable that can
be and
um
to really she really you watch it she
she hangs her out to dry and she sits
back and like has this kind of like
judgmental tone it bothered me as
somebody who really likes britney i
hated seeing that because
brittany then is
has to do this performance which
i i can understand why she's embarrassed
by it because it's hard to commit to
something like it kind of it's what we
talked about um she was honest about
yeah um and
she did ellen did not help her out at
all
that's a tough i i thought she was maybe
exaggerating about but you can tell
watching this video that she is
embarrassed and but also also to her
point that she said
there's only so much you can lean into a
performance yes by coolio when you're a
a white woman i know you know i it's
it's so it's like it's
between a rock and a hard place i would
say it isn't possible to fully lean into
you can't without risking if anything
she leaned the other way she did where
she kind of played up her she she was
kind of not not coolioness yes yeah
that's a hard what has anyone's ever
said that sentence not coolioness
um
[Music]
probably you think only because coolio i
think that's a pretty co it's a common
enough karaoke song
that um i'm sure somebody one of your
hundreds of thousands of people so you
think someone has said it in the context
of karaoke probably hmm
where else would they say it i mean a
coolio cover band um
looking for it cleo cover uh there might
be a coolio cover band i bet there is i
bet people i mean people cover coolio
songs i don't know if there's a band
exclusive to coolio cover songs what
would it be called um
okay uh you're thinking gangster's
paradise yeah that's all i know that's
the only coolio song i know me too you
don't both have to only know kings of
paradise
this could not be more middle-aged this
show at this point um well there's a
real boomer moment it is you well you
used it up a little bit when you talked
about queefs at the beginning of the
show
and
and uh oral sex
um performed by your old friend's
parents
i can't believe it just to break the ice
well maybe do you think that's why i did
that
it's not breaking the ice the ice has
been broken because we work together
that's why i figured you know what i
think it is i think i was subconsciously
wanting her to know that she could give
her license to talk about whatever that
was um
you know so i'm gonna like lower the bar
either raise the bar lower the bar in
terms of speaking freely depending on
how you look at it
maybe that's otherwise i have no
explanation as to why i charged in with
queefs and
oral sex well i think it's easy to
explain like why you went from queefs to
oral sex that because once you were your
brain was on i was in that territory
yeah you were in that territory yeah but
um i didn't want to leave any queef
unturned
[Laughter]
i think the oral sex thing i i don't
find that as
odd as you do that they that they never
yeah because i think that like the
generation not no that too but not i
would say not having oral sex with your
partner for one year
is not that different from not having
oral sex with your partner for 60 years
oh really yeah because once you
establish it as something that you don't
do
then it all kind of i know but it seems
normal you know i know but it's there
that's the part i couldn't wrap my head
around and it's so much enjoyable but a
lot of things
think about all the things you can do
that you don't do that one that brings
you pleasure sexually that is
pleasurable yeah
i don't know if they're well exactly the
most things you haven't tried think
about what the potential for for sexual
gratification maybe i just i'm limited
in my imagination maybe but if you if
you thought about it for a couple
minutes you would be you're saying
there's more potential
there's so many things you can do that
you don't do sexually that you might
enjoy
okay you know what i mean so many you
think yeah i mean of course and now i'm
curious what yeah
well
i i just think though that specific act
yeah it's like like there's a lot of
it seems obvious is this like neil
patrick harris said to me yeah yeah like
okay things you can try that's true that
you haven't tried because the thing is
you've done it's a more conventional
approach yeah it's a sexual relationship
you're right you're right so not doing
that thing it seems bizarre to you
because it's such an integral part of
your sexual experience yeah but not
doing it maybe it means replacing with
something else or spending more time
doing other things
it doesn't seem all that crazy to me
it's unusual because it's something to
do
it is commonly like discussed maybe it
is it's commonly it's out and but maybe
we're maybe we're not being
respectful enough of that time and how
less common it was how to talk about
that stuff before that maybe we just
grew up during a time where
i don't know what it was what the
tipping point was for
that open discussion about oral sex
whether it was tv or married with
children or whatever touch point
we had i could see someone thinking of
it as
potentially
disease spreading or
germy in some way you know putting uh
yeah your mouth near the general well
it's funny that's on the surface it
seems a little well potentially
problematic though isn't it that's what
this older person said his father had
said oh really about
performing that act on a woman okay
which which i've objected to
anyway food for thought
yeah
food
[Laughter]
now i'm like rethinking whether i should
have been so incredulous
uh i mean the parents are no longer
alive so it's it's you know what else it
is i think is just to not have
experienced
something
together that is so pleasurable that is
so it's right there it's not like
yeah i know but my am i saying the same
thing yeah but i'm saying the same thing
now which is
there are so many things that are
potentially pleasurable sexually that
you haven't done
yeah things you haven't tried yeah i
guess that you might really that might
really bond you with someone that can
might be a connective force
i guess so this just seems like maybe
some some like sub genres of sexual
activity like yeah but but this i i
would put oral sex in the like top
category that's like one of the main for
to you
well
our equipment like what we have but
physiologically we have mouths we have
genitals we have fingers we have ten
fingers
your fingers are great
i'll i'll bring the fingers we have a
chin chin there are three there's pins
are part of the oral sex there's a
million toys that are made boys no i'm
talking about what we're not i'm trying
to make poo poo toys yeah but toys you
know what i'm gonna do right now right
when we're done
no right when we're done recording i'm
gonna drive over to mom's house
and steal her phone and delete her
podcast app
i don't know how to transition out of
this conversation but but did solemn fry
really go to your school oh yeah and i
really know that no no she didn't go to
the school she went it's to tomlinson
for a day
one student uh to visit you know what it
was that she was visiting
i think tomlinson's uh the middle of the
year too also
moonfry was punky brewster i don't think
i made that clear oh i i think people
know that i i don't know don't your
listeners know that not to really i
always think i'm offending somebody i
don't mean brewster it was a long time
ago you're right you're right that is a
long time ago now i'm sure there's been
other irritations
you're not really anyone under like 35
might have might not know exactly yeah
that's right but yeah punky bruce went
for a day to visit her friend who was i
think her dad worked for cbs was like a
big like a big honcho he was a muckety
muck yeah he was a head-honked show at
cbs
um
you're very proud that kid cudi likes
you
i know well that's so flame to brag
about no it's not but he's cool he's in
that easy documentary should we read it
yeah yeah i think so yes what about um
pretty are you proud that i didn't do a
lot of snow puns i did a few in utah you
asked her we were in this you asked her
as a matter of fact if she was proud
that you didn't and she was like yeah
and then like a really nice way she was
like oh you haven't knowing that you
have no you're right and you were like
no i mean during this interview not in
general she's like yeah because when you
were working together you did a lot well
because it was snowing so much in utah
was hard to avoid in fact in my little
notes here i wrote down quote are you
proud of me for not making a pun about
your name yet
[Music]
okay
all right here's a letter
um also you singing at last james the
first couple bars just at last
oh god
why do i do that why do i have an
instinct to do that and bail out it's
like her coolio performance i'm glad you
have the bailout instinct well yeah i
wouldn't imagine if you didn't
you would have a whole different
personality but you didn't have a
bailout instinct or would that be more
entertaining it'd be more entertaining
for me yeah
for me and it'd be more confident i'd be
leaning into it at last
my love i can't
i just don't have a good voice you have
an okay voice okay boys okay
okay god gives god takes away
are you saying i used to have a really
good voice you're good at other things
um
okay here we go ian this is a letter
from ian subject catching up on some old
episodes tom green
hey long brothers i'm really that wasn't
a quote from tom green i don't think
hey long brothers i'm really enjoying
the podcast thanks ian
justin you are so funny in anything i've
seen you in to be honest i have not seen
it all but nonetheless still enjoy your
work
thank you ian uh where do you see it all
just wait christian i had no idea you
existed
until the podcast so sorry about that oh
that's okay yeah you don't mind that i
don't think i would know i exist if i
wasn't me or i didn't grow up in my town
yeah you probably didn't know enough or
what's until the school with me you
probably didn't know me
no i didn't tell this letter i didn't no
offense taken no no um ian williams by
the way i just glanced down at the end
okay
i just finished this tom green episode
and it hit so close to home i grew up in
alaska cool
homer in case you were wondering wow but
have lived in canada for the last eight
years i met my then to be canadian wife
while in costa rica he's all over the
place and a long but good story short
and two kids later we find ourselves
living in cottage country north of
toronto
um that is a very short version of that
it's like a yada yada yada yeah now
we're married in toronto yeah about four
hours to be clear oh sorry about four
hours
to be clear
um
four four hours north of toronto i heard
that's beautiful that's lake country
i've always wanted to go fishing up
there lake lake yeah um that might have
had a former therapist who used to take
uh he did there's a canoe trip that you
can do where you can like canoe through
all the lakes and you pick up the canoe
and walk it to the next lake wow
yeah it sounds really fun one day bucket
list um when i back to yen when i first
arrived in canada we actually lived in
alamer which is the town connected to
hull oh
hull we had we took a family vacation to
hall once um i i've never heard of
alamer i i don't mean any offense by
that
so anyway back then so anyway
interesting hearing well-known
individuals such as yourselves talking
about the area making me feel a
connection
i really connected with tom's pick for
another place to live for obvious
reasons i have been trying to make costa
rica my home for over a decade now just
at the point where we may be able to
afford something soon we shall see
speaking of costa rica we mentioned carl
kraut earlier in the show
carl for the few of you who don't know
him is uh kind of like the dude in big
lebowski he's a little bit like
jeff bridges character uh in the naples
version of and and carl said he was
going to spend the summer in costa rica
and we said oh
uh what are your plans what what do you
plan to do down there and he said i
don't know
and we said well uh how long are you
going to stay i don't know a couple
months
where are you staying i don't know so
he'll have a great time though yes he
will people have a great time anywhere
um anyway back to ian anyway i don't
know how weird it is for a commoner to
extend a commoner to extend an
invitation to go fishing or dad or to do
a number of other things this area has
to offer i know life is short as i fly
through my late 30s and see my kids
growing up right before my eyes two
girls malia is eight and ryla is four
there's no time like the present to
start living what a nice i wonder if um
she was named after malia obama i wonder
uh ryla ah malia and ryla nice names
i've wanted to write in after every
episode but find it lame to be man
crushing on someone you've never met and
never will meet
i don't think that's lame we as a
listener of the show you know we
we man crush
constantly on the reg yeah
um as the kids say you have you have
been one of my few podcasts i listen to
in the afternoon hours while i work so
thanks for keeping me entertained
sending so much peace and prosperity to
you guys much love and respect ian
williams thank you ian i didn't mean to
rifle through that ian williams
permaculture designer and master
carpenter cool
ah man lucky lucky to do both those
things permaculture it's like a
landscape architect i think so yeah and
two things i wish i were good at
carpentry two things i'm i i know i
can't do it all night no really and it's
funny he's the one who refers to himself
as a commoner in contrast to you like
your lordship but
you want to be able to do what he can
isn't that interesting i know i feel
that way about our friend in florida our
friend mick that some of the guys down
there think it's cool that i'm in movies
and stuff but i think it's so much
cooler the stuff they do uh it's all
perspective folks anyhoo that's a good
life lesson yes perspective matters um
grass is always greener
uh anyway okay okay enough gilda lily
uh so well thank you ian what a nice
letter and um
yeah i i i hope you get down to costa
rica because what a what a beautiful
and if you guys would like to write in
our email address is life is short at
wondery.com
write in
and if you like and we love man crush we
love to be crushed on by men
anyway thank you to everybody who
listened uh
and um and to brittany snow oh man what
an impressive human being ah
my pal a good pal and um i'm excited for
her she's directing a movie check it out
check out all her stuff she's just such
a she's a good person
in the world yes i'm glad she's out
there and i'm glad i know her and so
glad she did this so thanks for
listening and we will talk to you next
week life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted by you christian
long yes yeah again katie the allen and
producer megan the monaco how can i
forget senior producer is michelle
and the audio engineer is sergio
enriquez also executive producer
marshall louis and we all work for
wondering
[Music]
so i have a microphone here because i'm
told that after uh you'd work for the
day y'all would go out and sing karaoke
songs and there's a song what is your
go-to song my go-to song is uh
gangster's paradise by coolio okay well
i think it's uh i think uh you should
sing it for us
okay okay
just me no you i don't know it
oh gosh okay it's not well luckily this
is not singing so this is wrapping
twitch all right you can come out here
and help me as well if you're working oh
no it's just me
here we go go ahead smee all right
sing along
yep yep
oh a little intro
look how
cool i am
you